each team will have an All-Star representative
after tonight then you the fan will vote the rest
of the squads in the first 32 players tonight
and here's some notes first about the weekend
again there's going to be a player draft this time
around on February the 1st that'll be on ESPN 2
6:00 four teams selected by player captains each
Captain paired with the celebrity I'll be hosting
that show with David Amber up North so curious
to see how it goes hope it's not too awkward
uh February the 2 the skills competition on ESPN
of course PK mesh you'll be with me calling that
one this year look forward to it you were a four
for four acury shooter guy back in the day right
I love the skills I love the uh All-Star game
I it was such it was a proud moment for me to
make the uh Allstar my first time and you know
what was really amazing is how much the uh my
teammates were proud of me for making it well here
we go Sydney Crosby he is Penguins representative
again he's on Pace for 47 goals this year that
would be the second most in his career yeah best
player in my time in the league uh no question
about that still in the top five since the start
of last year no one has scored goal more goals
than David poer knock it's not off in Matthews
it's David PO he does it many different ways
he's got an amazing shot he can score from the
outside but it gets in the paint and it scores
in the cup areas as well someone's got to win
the style fashion guy of the the 30 goals and 35
games this year for Austin Matthews he might get
70 this year I think he's a most talented peer
goal scorer in the National Hockey League right
now Nikita CRA might be your MVP right now man
what a start he is off absolutely nasty uh this
guy continues to get better and find ways to put
the back puck in the back of the net and find his
teammates So Def definitely deserving for again
one player from each team selected tonight as you
can see and then you the fan eventually will get
us to the final number of 44 the graphics yeah
12 more players to go there are the first four
we talked about with video and then shurkin and
Hughes and naho and Barelle of course wow what a
what an amazing Sam Reinhardt having a career year
in a contract here ready kachuck is back darene
deserving Tom Wilson very deserving as well he's
had a great year some sandpaper at the All-Star
game and what what a story the Flyers are boom
Jenner broken jaw but he gets us get better and
go to the All-Star Game and represent Columbus